greetings from podcast Ville this
podcast is brought to you by zip
recruiter listen I know you're hiring
every business needs great people and
the best way to find them is with zip
recruiter something there's got to be
something better than posting your job
online and just playing for the right
people to see it at my line - you zip
recruiter learns what you're looking for
identifies people with all the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job the right candidates
are out there
zip recruiter knows how to find them
listen businesses of all sizes use
business zip recruiter for their hiring
needs so right now the church family
you give zip recruiter try it's free
gratis on the arm
it's a Muldoon don't worry about nothing
just go to zip recruiter comm slash
Church that's it that zip recruited our
town slash Church and get the employee
that you're looking for the right
applicant you understand me zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire I
also want to give a shout out to eyelet
on a.com since day one they've had my
back with the best supplements and
nutrients let me tell you something you
make yourself a little antioxidant tight
smoothie you get a little you get a
little uh s ie you get a little cherry
extract to take this thrown this out of
your muscles you put a banana in there
some blueberries and you throw a little
bit of that happy fourth of our force
acai protein in it and you blend that up
your dick gets hard for [ __ ] fish
understand me you want to keep walking
around with self dhikr you want your
dick to be [ __ ] pink like it's ready
to stab a [ __ ] in the lung you
understand me a little and calm and
press in church boom when you're ten
percent off delivered straight to your
[ __ ] casa I also want to give a shout
out to a greenhouse juice house on
Lancashire macrosse1 little unli Tita
those [ __ ] I throw in heating
there do you understand me when I'm
trying to heat
I even had kale for the [ __ ] first
time in there the other day because they
don't put the stems in it they just put
the least a little pineapple juice a
little quote they call it kale colada
are you [ __ ] nuts or what again
juice relieves the [ __ ] soreness in
your muscles after you jump up and down
all day with a bunch of [ __ ] savages
so I wanna give a shout out to the
greenhouse we take that [ __ ] meal
what are you [ __ ] nuts or what
fire so I go in Spanish for some of you
Spanish people it's a beautiful day to
be alive listen to my apologies listen
we try to change the show up so for a
few last few weeks you know the stars of
death are done so we've been laying back
on the edibles just for personal reason
dieting reasons and whatnot yesterday I
got a little froggy I was overwhelmed on
Monday and Sunday and I just needed to
blow off some steam but I want a little
deeper than deep yesterday I mean guys
I've been doing this podcast for six
years really and I've had some [ __ ]
heavy more momen see I know we've seen
the devil and we were [ __ ] up
yesterday I mean I don't know what
happened I didn't go to ballet I showed
up for pizza lathe I ate one slice of
pizza without even talking I just put it
in my mouth I went home after that I was
[ __ ] up I really wanted to go out to a
fourth warm to a spot I was so [ __ ] up
I went to bed and God knows what time I
think I was crawling in bed it was 10:00
to 10:00 and I slept straight till 5:00
oh that's great like I was just [ __ ]
high so my apologies will bring Wow we
will walk her back but today don't worry
about nothing I got my man Steve Salone
here in house one of the [ __ ] top
comics working across the country today
[ __ ] Philly [ __ ] raised and one of
my emotional support is what's happening
I love you Joey thanks for having so you
saw dice at the mall yes yeah and I was
with a buddy of mine from high school
and he couldn't like well this was
itself funny andrew is I see him walking
through Macy's with his bags and I Oh
Andrew and he just looks at me he goes
excuse me click he didn't even know it's
like everything's a goof to him and then
my friends like didn't know what was
going on and then Andrew made it
uncomfortable and then just started
laughing
come on he goes what I really wanted to
do is just pretend like I didn't know
you and just leave and then have you
think was that Andrew he was someone who
looked just like he is a professional
tortured check yeah it's Tuesday you
know can't sleep at night Mike Richter
uh like he just destroyed my crater like
he just destroyed my crater and Mike
Richter would try to tell me stories
about how he would go on the road and
Andrew and they'd be walking and talk
this huh until like a town
yeah yeah Guyot would come up to him I
know Andrew Dice Clay oh my god I love
you and he's like you want to go to the
show tonight and the guy said yeah I
really wanted to go to the show that's
when it was him the karate guy yeah
remember that's when there was a karate
guy me pasty face happy face me you
Pepsi what was his name the class so the
Kenny I never met club soda can you call
the security firm good security for
Andrew yep the karate guy have me you
when what was opening for now I never
saw him to do this me and Steve
experience something different with
Angela we Ricker said that they would
bump into somebody in a gang oh my god
it's a head you're Dice Clay and it'll
be six guys with Angela yeah and Angie
would talk to the people were you from
Long Island
oh my god I'm from Long Island with the
talk I mean when Brooklyn or whatever
yeah and then you know what I'm staying
at the four seasons of course room 608
at 7 o'clock and we'll get you tickets
ok right now we don't have a pen on us
that the phone would ring at 7 o'clock
on the dot
and somebody would answer hello who's
this hi this is Steve so long I mean
Andrew who Steve who Steve [ __ ] who I
don't know the Andrew you know Steve's
alone no no no no they listen he says
you don't know who you are but he let
you talk ah
and you'd be going yeah we met earlier
and I'm from Staten Island remember we
talked earlier he said hold on hold on
let me get somebody else on the phone
and they might start on him like what
who's this Steve's a mom remember you
guys medicine that one boy Steve let me
ask you a question would you give
tickets to some of you just met and it
would just be [ __ ] 10 min
to him then they would pass him to
Ricker uh and Ricker would have to torch
room for 20 minutes then they would pass
him somebody else for 10 minutes and
then they would finally get me to hand
your and you will go go [ __ ] yourself
and hang up on the poor guy
ah and I'd never do that to a person
yeah yeah it was just hysterical
and then the phone would ring and it was
and you're gone pick up the tickets in
the front like you know like [ __ ] like
that like that's what they got you
remember going to the restaurant that
time with Andrew he torment we did a
show he knew every Bobby Lee and Jim
Norton or it was me you and Jim Norton
this has to go 98 this has to be 2000
okay
2001 problem is when I first started
there and so we went and he took us to a
diner and he ordered some and he would
send it back constantly he's got too
much lettuce it's got two little lettuce
I don't like to talk now the toast is
called
the boogie you went back and forth not a
toast is called can you remake me a
sandwich and they remake the sandwich
and he's trying on something no you
don't wanna I want a sandwich anymore
let me get a bowl of soup oh that's what
he does to tournement that's what he
that's for fun that's what he does for
fun so there's something he [ __ ] the
house about it to some people it sounds
dickish but at the end there's a payoff
he always yeah turns it around he'll let
you know it's a joke yeah he gets the
people laugh and away they're like okay
we had some laughs like he did this once
he was peod bought a house in Vegas and
he needed to buy everything for the
house everything so I'm with him for two
weeks we're going on like Macy's home he
robbed that place behind every store in
the mall and now he's got bed so we have
to buy beds he bought four beds and he's
hammer like for fun he would negotiate
prices he get sales people frustrated
ripping up books he would we okay with
the beds he did filing the owner of the
stores just like what fine just leave
I'll take whatever you want right so he
gets the four beds was he doing for
material or is he just doing it from
different formats like his version of a
video game is playing with people he
does not he just tortures people and
everything is a mind thing yes and it's
very smart that's how he became who he
is
yes mind how he did things he told me an
interesting story wants about booking
crime story mm-hmm how this is way
before social media he was really big on
the East Coast
hmm and he went from Boston to Miami he
was already selling out he was starting
to do the hickory dickory dock your
mother sucked my [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] and he got a call one day
and he goes I gotta go down and do a
[ __ ] audition this is when the Comedy
Store was The Comedy Store Kennison was
still alive you know nobody's having a
good time yep and he said that he went
in into his audition like into it at
that time to a guy like me in that
position when I heard this story I
thought it was just insane he said
because I was doing good as a comic he
goes I knew the role was for me so I won
and then I [ __ ] him I go what'd he
mean you're [ __ ] me was I read
everything backwards I go so wait a
second you went to read for Michael Mann
but for a [ __ ] TV show and you read
everything backwards hmm and he goes
yeah but in between the words I would do
the character and talk like the
character they were looking for so it
didn't really [ __ ] matter hmm
that's Jeanne Jeanne type shed okay that
that was a genius so what he was doing
was he told the [ __ ] first off when you
go into an audition you and your weakest
point as a human being you're about to
get judged you're going up in front of
[ __ ] Judas
whoever little sentence Jesus the judge
you get judged on your acting what you
look like if you're right for the role
God knows so many things on so many
different levels and you feel it when
you walk in them mm-hmm it's really good
once you learn to take control of that
situation I went through i'ma tell you
right now if you're an aspiring actor
and I got it
and I can't see a person from I can't
see lead listening to me and going in
there tomorrow and doing what I'm Tony
Lee doesn't have the chops I'm not
taking anything away from Lee Lee
doesn't know what it is to go up in
front of five people for two weeks in a
row he does but he doesn't you know like
it's weird
when you have an audition and we do
stand-up what I finally realized was I
was doing stand-up in the room I was god
I was going in there as an actor I said
[ __ ] that I'm going as I learned how to
turn I don't never forget the dad turned
one line into three and when I went back
to shoot it they wrote it that way Wow
because it was one line but I made it
three to stay in the room longer than
anybody else
wow those you're gonna audition it's
just a revolving door yeah that's a
gasps I didn't want to be part of that
revolving door so what I did was I would
stay in there longer and that would [ __ ]
with everybody else's head that was
standing that because the last 10 guys
went in and out of that I would read it
wrong I would let it fall I will let the
sheet fall on the floor I would do
anything I could to last more than three
seconds hmm because of the story Andrew
Dice Clay told me that he made them
leave that let the camera running so he
they could capture him doing all that
dumb [ __ ] in between yeah usually you've
got right ready Lee you're ready all
right move one three two one so where
were you the night of November 12th and
you'll go I was at home my mother all
right watching jeopardy or something
like that but the line was the Hollywood
Squares yeah and you say jeopardy go cut
that's right there he would say don't
say don't cut let it roll just keep
moving
Wow right there that thing
you just controlled the room yeah but it
takes two [ __ ] things between your
legs hanging deep to do that because
when you go to the audition and you
actually see people walking in it's
really wigs do you Simone you don't know
what it's like when people cower
yeah like I've seen all levels of people
in auditions I've seen the people walk
in like I walk into an audition now like
but I learned that in spider-man 2 mm
when I went to read for spider-man to
her bring that movie
everything that room to read was
somebody you saw yeah in a big movie an
antic won't look at them like oh you
know what they don't have the Comedy
Store at midnight yep no these people
could do that [ __ ] them alone and then
[ __ ] it up and boom the next day I
books by the bed - I remember reading an
interview with Bill Murray and he said
early on Gilda Radner was amazing at
auditions because she was rich she
didn't need the money she didn't have
any pressure on her and he was just
starving for his next meal so it was
like I realized by watching Gilda that I
had it going and not care what happened
he was like the only way I could be
myself and be loose was to go in there
go all right don't you see what where it
lands it's [ __ ] crazy it's crazy
I've seen people at an audition dressed
like the character you lost there yeah
once they tell you address number one
time then I got a call from Ari
you get that audition I go yeah here
tomorrow we all dress up like 17th
century soldiers or something like the
1846 and you know how he's like when I
[ __ ] mind I'm gonna sue for 1846 he's
like [ __ ] that man yeah I'm going in
there like I'm going in there he goes
what are you gonna do I go I'm not going
in there at all great I'm not even gonna
[ __ ] with it and like they want you to
wear some Confederate suit or something
like that some [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you
and where everyone else is going to the
costume store getting Confederate suits
and you go to those auditions and those
people dress like chefs
you just lost yeah you lost he's a boss
so what do you think the real secret
thought is I'm gonna wear white t-shirt
gotcha I would still wear white t-shirt
but I would never put the ships to sleep
at heart and he ever gone there was an
apron no I would wear a white t-shirt
I'd give them the appearance doubt what
they're looking for you're looking for a
cop I wear blue only slur shirt but I
won't want a cop uniform with jeans and
sneakers that's it's the same effect
yeah so like it's picture you know it's
all your mind game I go back to that
morning audition I did where I called
for a guy on this patio with a big set
heavyset guy watering his plants
wouldn't think that you know you would
see people the old school thing no no
with a whole sucka but you ever see
people that wear like bikinis on the
beach and willing to walk past men and
they go who like this guy did not need a
bikini on yeah but when I got to the
audition I saw all these Italian dudes
bro that would [ __ ] me up in an audition
I go they're all gonna get in ice pop
quick ago I got underwear on and I got
sweats on I like I'm gonna take a chance
and I walked into the room and they go
give us a minute that's what as they
turn around I said perfect
I took my [ __ ] sweats off and when
they turned back around I took my shirt
off I was just there was no tighty
whities not and I have something one of
the hot dogs or something like that and
I was it that was it I knew it was
lights out yeah because nobody else
thought of going in there with a pair of
bikini this is the time to wear the
costume in Liz's I'm not throw I have
this [ __ ] uh-oh
Silence of the Lambs was on last night
and I was watching this for a little
while and then Hannibal came on right
after that on HBO and it was casted by
this guy that cast Donnie Brasco Wow
he cast a bunt DGM eluded gemelas name
is he even cast Godfather - Wow
he went to high school with the real
Donnie Brasco oh my god Joe Pistone
yes oh and Joe Pistone
did the movie Joe went to him and said I
want you to cast a movie they were
friends we [ __ ] that's awesome
but I did a cold reading workshop with
him at UCLA this is one me and Terry
could barely pay rent and Terry paid a
hundred $1 for a workshop Wow Bryan
Callen was there this is 2001 yeah
mm this is 2001 Bryan Callens there and
I took the workshop home with me the
worksheet yeah I still have the
worksheet it's in my daily journal Wow
so whenever I get an audition she
doesn't get the audition I take the
sides I put the yellow and I smoke a
joint
I had to breathe it a couple times and I
leave it alone then I come back and I
give it the flavor but before I go to
that audition I pull that checklist out
and his checklist is [ __ ] evil like
don't go in there to book the job going
there to be remembered mmm you know if
you're gonna go in there and light the
room on fire light on fire and not don't
go don't go you know like he has a lot
of things that you make sure you have
the carriage like I can't remember off
the top of my head I'd love to take a
look at oh my god to be Radha
that shit's the buyer she cuts my gist
she codes like just two pages of what
and I write little things on the sheet
to remember but one thing it is don't go
in there to book the job going there to
be remembered it's genius that [ __ ]
line right there is [ __ ] classic like
he book sleepers hmm but he said they
looked at Jennifer Lopez Jennifer Love
Hewitt
but one day he got off he got to his
[ __ ] office and there was a shoe
hanging on his doorknob and it said how
do I get my foot in the door and a note
in the resume and it was - chickadee
Hyatt Wow the Australian chick that
plays the Puerto Rican shake Wow
definitely [ __ ] so for like that's
awesome TV shows and movies like they
obviously have the bigger roles but for
like always like smaller roles how many
people will they see for them ah 15 got
cut it down to six producers it's still
a lot of people I trying to like trying
to
differentiate between if that's the type
they're looking for they're looking for
a Steve Simone type and gonna look at a
people right yeah you're gonna cut it
down to four for producers and then let
the producers decide that's a lot of
people that like to be remembered but
think about goal for commercial dish
you're going against sixty oh my god at
a commercial edition I've only gotten
callbacks when I go into the audition
everybody looks like me sometimes they
don't know what they're looking for ya
know those everybody I go you know I
don't know yeah I don't do not even
worth it
I get calls every one small hey take a
look at this audition it's a great role
and you read it and you go you have to
look at the scene and hash yourself do
you belong to this [ __ ] scene and
you'll go no I don't and they don't know
what they're looking for
yeah guess what I ain't got that type
it's a waste for behind eleven o'clock
at Warner Brothers I pick around over
there
yeah I'll start with poor lows on the
way back okay you know say I'm like a
nice day yeah well for 30 or for Beverly
rule Boulevard
you gotta go over the hell you don't let
me loose it's four o'clock go [ __ ]
yourself you're in no danger
you got a better chance of [ __ ]
rollerskating do you have a brother
chance of rollerskating the hell and
Megan lingo down there that's crazy
this really is add some weird [ __ ] this
we get kind of weak you have this week's
leaves alone pretty good I did my first
I did a corporate yesterday at nine
o'clock in the morning for most of the
people in the room couldn't even speak
English oh they could speak English but
it wasn't their first language and it
went great
I'm like this Harlem you had for PG the
guy saw me at the Comedy Store
no [ __ ] yeah I was like this is great
they sent me an uber I felt like a big
shot and it was right on the levers at
the Annenberg beach house on a right on
the beach in Santa Monica so it was a
great way to start my day and then uh
I've been workin out it's good how to re
I'm gonna go to Ari's place for a month
you are yeah in Australia yep while he's
in Australia be in New York yeah what
dates
I'm gonna be in well after after I get
back from Canada on the 13th I'm gonna
come back to LA for that weekend and
then I'm gonna fly to New York I'm at
Monday or Tuesday which is what like the
16th or 17th of April of April all the
way through like May 21st and then I'm
gonna come back and forth for a couple
things but I'm gonna try to do that
month in New York I'm excited Dayak yet
now don't you want a book like all those
little places I reached out to Ari
hooked me up with the stand they're good
guys over there people very good people
and then Amy Hawthorne that used to hang
out at the Comedy Store she's booking a
club there so if I just get a couple
dates stuff my face eat something
delicious get to be in New York take the
bus back to Philly to see my nephews
I'll be I'll be happy it'll be a good
month that's good you're at that stage
now or it's good that's yeah it's good
fun it's just fun you do what the [ __ ]
you want you're really looking to write
you know I'm looking to really act if
somebody calls you exactly yep
what was it like stand-up at 9:00 in the
morning was the earliest I've ever done
a show but most of the people that were
from Finland and they're very polite
people
and they love American stand-up comedy
and it was great it was wonderful I
can't wait to do more of that stuff
because it was like positive like
businesspeople they loved it I didn't
think I'd be able to pull it off but it
worked
so this boy ed did something this week
at the two things out of my comfort zone
I went to jujitsu at 90 island which is
scary as [ __ ] I was really overwhelmed
this week yeah you know Sunday's podcast
with Joe or al Merrill [ __ ] me up a
little bit so cool not the one Monday as
much as Sunday because like I said when
I run them around Cuban refugees I get
this sense of guilt
mmm-ma my douche yeah you know I'm
saying but I did pay my dues in other
ways try didn't pay my dues that way
yeah and that's why I have a rough time
talking to my [ __ ] sister on the
phone because numb was to say I'm either
hello man just feel weird all around but
it was really overwhelming Monday and
after Rodin's I dropped him what we went
got a juice at the G spot over crossing
the Laemmle they got like a Pattaya Bowl
there what they were loving it there
they will love it they had been there
like three [ __ ] times I took them the
first day they're like this dis is this
is for what the [ __ ] the juices balls
the acai bowls the Pattaya they got a
bunch of good like bay but have oatmeal
Wow that'll blow your [ __ ] mind would
have milk is [ __ ] like that just
delicious [ __ ]
so that Monday night after the podcast
was done I dropped them off and I went
back to say my goodbyes like I'm gonna
try them all I was just home alone hmm
I walked in the house and I forced
myself to do a spot at the fourth wall
okay even though I was overwhelmed as I
was at [ __ ] Thai like the more that
they started at 8:07 yeah and it was
7:15 but I was just sitting down for the
first time it was the podcast so I got
up at 8 I you know play with my daughter
15 minutes I talked to my wife I did my
little ritual now with the kickboxing at
9:00 I got on that took a shower pick
Joe Yoel up and those guys at 10:30 and
got him up to Rogan then finish with
them entertain them for an hour to drop
them off before their flight and then I
went home
picked up mercy played with her for a
while and then left her we're back to
the hotel I got with them waiting for
that car to come and then I went home
and finished off the night with mercy
and at 9 o'clock i shadow over to the
4th wall you at the dedication to go
back to the fourth wall design o'clock
this is what we do as comedians bro
that's incredible people just don't get
it they don't get it and if I don't you
know a couple years ago when I started
doing this podcast with Lee and stuff
like that
something took all my life that was
really weird I was responsible for my
hmm so now I break people's balls well
people come in here and learn something
from them I try to implement them in any
way that I can because I see that it's
working for them yeah something works
with somebody and you're watching it
that's it gameland
that's it this is the way I'm doing it
yes whatever I've been doing it I've
been doing it right you guys are we
talking about when he started the
podcast someone chanted over your life
and it did it made me be more
responsible
it made me you know first thing go out
of your comfort zone in time to time
yeah if not nothing [ __ ] happens in
your life her nothing will happen you
live this life like a [ __ ] putz
so the a night I picked up merci after
some classes she's like Daddy I just
wanna go home when we got home she said
something about [ __ ] she wanted to
play a game I know you know what I'm
gonna leave for now and I'll come back
and he dinner she goes okay and I put my
gear I flew over there I didn't know I
was I roll three times we come on now
but when I got in that car
I'd done something different then I got
dressed and went did two spots at the
store that's incredible I did tripolis
room and the [ __ ] original that's it
this is what we do yeah what you know
people who live in shock and I have to
let but you know like me I got a call
lino what the [ __ ] you got up kid Kenny
oh this is this is it yeah I've been
doing it since I was 21 I don't know no
other way
yeah people don't realize how much
wormwood takes behind the scenes yeah
people do no [ __ ] idea then they get
wall I want so much out of life but I
just saw you Sunday watching the
football game
do not I can't run the last time I sat
down and watched I don't know what I
totally that you're becoming a comic now
miles look if this is what you want to
do throw your TV oi yeah next time you
see somebody that's the next level of a
commitment when you go take the TV I
haven't been watching it like I finally
this wha this week I on Tuesday I
finally felt like a real Club you go to
one place and I had three spots oh
that's great I went well
yeah for me they're out here that's
great for me you can't talk the talk
unless you walk the walk
yeah how can I tell these kids at home
that this is what you need to do yep
whether your 5585 I said I'm ashamed of
myself at 55 look around white he does
it 61 I'm ashamed of myself but he goes
out for months weeks a month and drinks
yeah he just not only goes out he
there's tequila and whatever thought
that if a Colombian shows up brief
little two roots you know I give my hats
off to that guy yeah but people do not
understand the extreme of the work and
the [ __ ] you're running a business
you're running a business
what if your business if three employees
get sick for three weeks
it ain't gonna run that means you gotta
take care of yourself
yep that means you gotta take care
yourself you know all those little
things you got drink water you gotta
write who the [ __ ] am I not to go to the
fourth one on Monday night who the [ __ ]
am i I'm not doing a podcast I'm going
to sit there for three hours with two
women talk about what and talk about
what right now it takes one hour takes
one hour gonna do the [ __ ] fourth war
and you always learn something you will
always learn something as a comic so I
moved to LA I didn't know about TV yeah
I know nothing about TV when people said
to me Joe Rogan's on Newsradio I thought
it was a radio show that's what I knew I
nothing and then did I not even give a
[ __ ] right I don't know anybody I didn't
give a [ __ ] about what was on TV I
didn't give a [ __ ] what this ball was
but your mother's favorite show was I
don't forget don't tell me a nice eyeful
people were like nobody's gonna come to
the show yes they are
yeah because as Americans like me I
don't give a [ __ ] and sure enough there
were 60 people there sign for final
[ __ ] show yep you know when you want
to do something your life changes you
have to [ __ ] change it it's not what
you want to do little more it's what
needs to be done those are two
completely different sentences it's all
I wanted to know that's what you wanted
to but that's not what needs to get done
yeah if you make it a need you
yeah yeah are you good yeah I don't care
you said you if you were on that piece
of paper you're going to the gym I don't
give a [ __ ] if you walk in there at
midnight
yep but you're gonna [ __ ] do it yes
and people refuse to do that and this
law haven't elicit any no why do I have
credit card debt why don't I have the
things I want because you can't he'll
make a commitment the one [ __ ] thing
yes one [ __ ] thing
I was so let's let's put our cards on
the table here
mmm the last time I was proud of myself
really really proud of myself
wasn't I got picked to go to five star
basketball camp when I was 14 years old
Wow
that was the last time I was as
overwhelmed as I was Monday for more
reasons than one I got to y'all Romero
looks like a villain on paper but even
without meeting him I knew what his
heart was because I've been there and I
know that yeah I wanted him to my first
question to him the only question I
wanted for this podcast was who are you
hmm you know I wanted to touch his heart
that this podcast is about you know that
was a good thing number two my friend
opened up and jujitsu school I wanted to
help him out I wore his t-shirt I'm
wrong and that was done injury another
friend of mine said he wanted to picture
a little mean the world firm I got him a
picture with him crying it was one of
those days where I made people's day I
got my day may they get the same your
day with the podcast it was a really
perfect good [ __ ] day yeah that's how
life's supposed to be I'm sick and tired
of you know what man I'm a comic and I
got a little bit of an attitude mm-hmm
and I got my [ __ ] golf style you
demons we all do yeah but I gotta tell
you something man
my goal every day when I wake up stir
beside getting on stage and trying to be
productive and trying to take care of
myself is to make somebody's day that's
it that's the secret it's been so
important to me lately with a joke call
somebody
yes my friend's dad
not invited down to the story and then
he showed up he's bearing this fallen on
Saturday he showed up he needed a so
he's down there like half home he comes
in first thing I got a box from speed
we'd a big shout out to my man Gino from
speed weed he's the great if you're in
the valley and you need weed delivered
to your house go to Gino he should have
put a utility belt are--for the box of
[ __ ] edibles for me and [ __ ] they
were 15 milligram anibal's but my friend
his dad just died I said walk me to my
car he didn't know he had no idea what
he was getting himself into he came over
he goes what's going on like he was no
like nervous I could see that his pain
oh and I gonna eat some edibles [ __ ]
and he goes well somebody hit everyone's
like I [ __ ] up I'm not sure I got you
don't need to be sure here I just gave
him a piece of trouble in the a home
when there was 15 milligrams and he goes
I think this is all I could have my god
not tonight my game another one from 15
milligrams definitely wasn't like a
woody drinking because I think yeah I
think I'm just gonna have a water I go
no no what are you drinking he goes rock
atomic like he knew he wasn't getting on
their lives
yeah and then [ __ ] he got him a seats
in the original they got to watch Joe
and he got a was what Sally won and
Sebastian oh my er lion I'll be gone off
the stage and who's at the store Victor
with Kevin Gelman the UFC fighter on a
mission I saw that picture in the back
in the smoking lounge having gassed them
in these [ __ ] hug at me he I
introduced him to me as I kind of [ __ ]
is this happening I don't know do and
then Theo von shows up with Mickey job
why Joe whatever feeling Schilling from
the Bellator champion with Ian Edwards
the old UFC fighter they show up he's in
the back either jiu-jitsu guy his father
just died and he's in the back smoking
with him Kevin gasp oh man then the
[ __ ] not it whenever they were
worried smoking with him they won the
back by hanging out and he was smoking
with a bunch of comics and me Kevin gas
them and Victor rogue and we're all
sitting on the other side of the [ __ ]
thing and everybody's [ __ ] smoking
double and looked on the one
he looked a minute just winked and I
felt so [ __ ] good about myself the
office I am like I made this [ __ ]
night he just winked at me and the nice
unlist I got it I got the five year old
I gotta get up in the morning bro
they're like oh you need anything call
me and I go I'm sorry you know and it
was just nice like it was just two days
that was just nice but the first day
[ __ ] Monday when I walked in from the
hotel I threw my sneakers off I put my
feet up and I was like wow that was just
overwhelming yeah and I was watching
some [ __ ] show on TV and I scrolled to
see what was on oh my god reals TV on
the Outlaw Josey Wales from the part
where he saves the Indian Sheikh from
getting raped oh good I watched that for
about 30 minutes all the way up to the
part where he shoots the [ __ ]
stranger off the soldiers boat and they
floated away
and then and then all the best is the
old Indian that selling that tonic and
[ __ ] peasant that's a scene when he
goes up to the anything-goes this of
people can't handle their alcohol and
the Hindi an insult to me and then Clint
Eastwood knocks him down on the way out
and now they show again and he's got to
jack it off using his [ __ ] ointment
to get the dirt off his white jacket as
he was a Salesman you know Josey Wales
is one of those westerns that's just
funny like it has a little a little
monotone from the eastern one and after
I watch that bro I went over I mentally
at the fourth wall and I did my spot but
yeah people wide white tonight I'm gonna
go down into a few spots I'm out tonight
yeah it's Thursday about tonight the
more I'm gonna acupuncture a week so
look are you gonna go to the store
tonight - yeah I got a 1045 so why wait
you know maybe I'll do an hourly spot at
the fourth wall then just go to you boy
huh I think I'll leave the house only
the house at 9:00
I'll do the fourth wall I'll tell Joey
I'll leave right after my spot at night
there you know [ __ ] be down there by
10:00 watch two or three comics I took
it Sebastian and Mark Maret oh my gosh
when I come home I eat a bag of dicks
like I did the other day and I come home
I know biggest their [ __ ] feelings
hurt and I did my four five spots for
the week I'm doing a spot Saturday for
the [ __ ] Irishman at The Improv so
I'm good oh you're doing great
Fitzsimmons show yes I did my goal for
the week that's great
that's me nobody cuz their feelings hurt
if I stay in town I'm still gonna do 20
sets a month totally through sets of
that's the number for me again you know
when I first got here I needed Riya a
night that's 21 a week that's [ __ ] 84
a month if I could do dirty I'd be happy
Wow
yeah that's that's the work ethic every
time sniffle I need to work harder like
we all be do I have to work harder like
I hear that and I just go okay well
there's no excuses you got to do more we
all need to work harder people it's it's
it's really crazy that the last couple
years I've seen one more people that
have looked at me and shine I always
knew you how to work harder whatever you
wanted to do I was just scared of the
work yeah I was always scared of the
work yeah up to the age of 34 I was
scared to work I'm not gonna lie nobody
I was actually scared of working and
once you realize that it's either this
or die right it's either this or at
least eat or get the things that you
want to eat you know what you don't have
the lobster but it's nice not to get
that turkey packaged bunch of chemicals
shine is nice to get a nice slice there
turkey from the Boar's Head
Dali's force adversary Hey
those name yes you can be dolla bread
you can go to the dollar store and get
bread weights and - Wonder Bread and
[ __ ] with some males and some lettuce
and you know it's up to you I'm not
saying you gotta be brigitte bardot but
those are the decisions you have to make
I'm living off Wendy's $0.99 menu yeah
well that first moved to our life why I
was a difficult call uncle and that's
the decision I made
I'll will I also ended up to four
hundred eighteen pounds eatin those
[ __ ] Wendy's nine lancets mine you
know when I go in there no you but then
one day I'm like listen for me to live I
got like a little human being I gotta
find my own eggs I gotta eat two pieces
Oscar my center cut bacon from the
middle it'll give you that [ __ ] hog
you ever cooking bacon you smell when
it's hog yeah it's in the yeah you can
smell it you know I mean those are the
decisions you have to make and then you
start saying well now I need to make
1,200 a month to fourteen hundred a
month to sixteen hundred a month yeah
you know what you won't make it the
first three months but all of a sudden
you'll start making 1,600 a month yeah
especially when you need to do it yeah
when you put it out into the universe
and you actually work you know when
you're working that's true you know when
you're working nothing happens on the
bed and nothing happens on that [ __ ]
couch nothing nothing and to get you
know you look at these Olympians I have
read an article three weeks ago do you
know what it cost to become an Olympian
no idea we think pays for their training
we think the US the Olympic sends them
money every month and you you in your
parents Wow yeah they do it just for the
love of it which is they do it for a lot
of it that's incredible
how incredible is that that they digs
all they do everything that you need to
do it yeah once you get to a certain
level I'm sure that you get some
sponsorship money but I just read an
article but the guy who put 80 grand in
this credit card for three years or so
Wow
80 grand a year on this credit card
something just ridiculous
no now is he gonna get sponsors is
somebody gonna help him with that now
that later on you get sponsors I guess
you get something for away if you win
the medal but that's
Cheerios commercial you know once that
runs out what's what's gonna do a
commercial get three to seven grand
what's 80 [ __ ] random that will do it
seven grand you'll have a party gonna
sniff cocoa some of these Teddy's wait
think you're gonna do I don't know but
it did it's a lot of finally I've been
very lucky the last couple weeks to get
to do shows with Steve and same Triple E
and Joey not uh but it's like I'm at a
place like just I'm just amazed when I
hear how long you guys have been doing
it but if I do one spot it makes me want
to go do it like for whatever like it's
so much fun and it makes you want to go
do another I felt guilty because the
other day you said something mean oh
well these guys are doing this I told
you not to do not to get involved with
that because I know the value of dollar
one and I know what a spot this is a
spot it's a spot it's a spot I don't
give a [ __ ] when you get in your car
drive to Wyoming or whether you get in
the car and you have to Sherman Oaks a
spots a sponsor spot now I'm worried
about your time well yeah what's worth
your time you're following like yeah
it's father Steve Simone says to you hey
I'm doing the volcano room in Portland
Oregon I can't pay you but you sleep on
the floor and you guess that [ __ ] yeah
that's your brother you know he gets 10%
off at the restaurant you know Sam but
for you to get any time going through
the unknown that no and you got the
fourth wall call [ __ ] Rizzo called
Johnny Rock they got a room somewhere
right I just I like I've heard some of
these stories about you guys wanting
from spot to spot and they're always
gives me a little bit of anxiety because
I don't like being late places but like
I just had so much fun the other night I
had I got in line and I got my spot at
the pizza place but then I ran and did
the skip town Playhouse was Steve Dez
and but then that ran a little bit late
so I had to run back up to North
Hollywood so make your season oh and I
was wanting from my car and they call
her they call my name so I didn't get to
and I did that and I went over to the
fourth wall I just like I finally felt
like an actual comedian of what you like
the season so you get some when they go
oh we forgot the show is not gonna start
at 8:30 we gotta wait I just returned to
the land that's the night that you're
getting 75 bucks at 10:00
ooh and the leg is going to overtime
you're saying like oh man I'm getting 75
hours I can go eat tomorrow I get a bag
of weed and all of a sudden you get down
there for the small 20 and they tell you
without waiting we got away from a game
then then you're like what not only that
not only that you waiting for the lady
game ten you also drove down honey
because you only got 16 dollars on the
ATM you need 20 to take money out of
there ah so you could charge five on
your [ __ ] card on the gas but you
really don't want to
so the 22 they were gonna give you the
20 and the drink ticket at that gig you
need that 20 because that 20 was gonna
get you to your next gig that's gonna
catch other 75 so now you can't do that
because the Laker game delayed you
that's why once basketball season comes
the calmly it changes in your name but
same thing happens if you were busted
you're gonna do an open mic and Boston
and turn off a hockey game yeah a Red
Sox game good luck good luck I'm turning
off a [ __ ] Celtic game on a Tuesday
night when they're at home
good luck I had a neighborhood and done
[ __ ] Dorchester or something like that
good luck my friend same thing happens
yeah you gotta look at your schedule or
what about the times you book like your
book like a [ __ ] April in the town
and it's the week that they're in the
NBA playoffs ah nobody's saying and
nobody's there Doug nobody remember
going to Houston there being four people
four people couldn't get tickets you
ever been in Calgary when the flames
were doing a burnout mocking don't
forget it forget it
everything gets that you're excited is
so happy 22 people do you guys like look
at sports and like I know not to be mean
but do you look at it like wishing they
lose like please oh now you get pissed
every club owner hates the local team
mention to a club owner hey do you go to
something game [ __ ] you want a causeway
every time they go on a playoff they
can't wait for [ __ ] basketball season
to be over because now they could go
back to making money from its [ __ ]
crazy League there's basketball and
hockey season [ __ ] this hell yeah [ __ ]
like Denver Nuggets yeah go into a bar
and combi city and tell them we're
turning off the game in the third corner
that's so funny it's yeah it's a lot to
compete with especial it's free on TV
Denver there's no reason to stay in then
when a Sunday night their football
season now if she books you from
September to December on a Sunday just
go windy I'd rather not live through
that because if they win it's a good
time and if they lose it's not a good
time you don't want to be in the middle
of that you don't need the 50/50 or $50
I love it yeah because nobody's gonna
show because they're partying if they
win this one o'clock game and then ain't
nobody coming to see you tonight on a
Sunday when it's 80 degrees and it's
November in the Lord's Day on the Sunday
they start drinking that cause water in
the water flowin you were a Ewing a
Ewing I know that is a party town that's
a Denver Bronco town yeah
I don't go to [ __ ] Bronco Ville I
don't [ __ ] with the Broncos I learned
early I was a thief in Denver that's
time to rob a [ __ ] mall is when the
Broncos on nobody's in the hallway
watching the TV yeah you're walking
through the mall putting on sure it is
those savages in Boston Rob Rob
Gronkowski's house during the Superbowl
damn that's how you rob but but you
think the cops are gonna respond to a
lot right the cops eight bucks an hour
this little white for industry as well
yeah
the Super Bowl he's gonna shut it off
put it on the seat put the car and drive
get the electricity going are you
[ __ ] kidding me
that's how to do things it's crazy but
there's so many aspects Takami I haven't
been doing triple runs we're talking
about triple ones little Dan last week
and going into the room and you have
this material office and it says in the
bottom oh by the way this is a Mormon
room you can't talk about all these
topics these are all the learning curves
these are all the [ __ ] [ __ ] is this I
almost broke my hold on just now you see
that humbles just armbar myself right
there you imagine bringing your own mom
on the desk I'd be the biggest more
light a likes you're killing myself last
week with the PES model what I put the
tens machine on my back that [ __ ] that
gives you electric shock when I wash my
hand I felt smoke coming out of my ears
I tell you we had to come over and put
crazy glue on my tongue last week oh
yeah again I put sleep apnea well I left
your house and the [ __ ] glue the
sleep apnea heat you made the glue
expand it'll look like a building when I
woke up the next more than I did gold
tooth I felt like that I was like a
[ __ ] oh my god you know I've had the
bad luck in the world tell them what
that about that night where you came out
looking like you were in a horror movie
your t-shirt was bloodied up and then as
soon as we got the gum on it the
whatever done the gum the glue on your
tongue he was rolling a joint I had to
lick the joint as soon as he got blood
on it he's like it's okay it's good for
you the other side he came up with 12
becomes oboz' talk down offer you
adjoint he offered me a mini doughnut
and then he and then he was joint and
taking edibles meanwhile his tongue was
bleeding like it was like usual I bite
my tongue you bite your tongue you take
a xanax does that explodes out of the
counter I don't think that what kind of
glue do you put on it crazy crazy glue
he whether it happened once before with
Jerry Rocha and Jerry brought like not
name-brand Krazy Glue and it didn't work
so here
it's still healing Porto Rican crazy go
to the dollar store this [ __ ] don't do
that you put your helmet on
it was the [ __ ] yeah I've seen her
tongue bite dog that was a year I would
crazy google people's phones I just
would Krazy Glue their photo you would
do that I had crazy glue and I would
crazy Google there was a salesman
they'll always take the sales call
uh-huh
so I would crazy who was fall from time
to time though yeah they would drive his
hand to receive so it's he kind of pick
it up yeah he couldn't pick it up oh my
god so I was a killer with Krazy Glue
where did you get so much Krazy Glue you
have no idea what fun is do you get
crazy you put glue on somebody's door
with the car door oh they can't get it
oh no yeah I [ __ ] with people all the
time when Krazy Glue oh yeah four years
in Colorado one of my my first criminal
mentor I the first guy that taught me
weaponry should Krazy Glue is the
biggest weapon in the world you could
glue somebody's hands together it's
[ __ ] crazy ain't doing anything by
the time they pull it apart their
[ __ ] skin comes off if I put crazy
glue on your palms a lot of crazy will
put your hands together I could smack
the [ __ ] are you for ten years
ah by the time you pull your palms
together skin's gonna come off you lose
some skin you know every ball from skin
Jesus crazy low is no joke why do you
know I can't get it off because woman's
uh now poor my nail polish remover he
was a green beret that's what he did
miracles with that stuff yeah those guys
are a different breed it can't be great
just to stab [ __ ] put crazy
glue around the cut that'd be great
what does that do no I just like that's
a move for John Wayne
the skin wasn't gonna be able to closers
and they were really gonna do it John
with TV show did you read that yeah am I
going crazy I think of a Keanu Reeves
I'm gonna do it yes okay that's a show
or watch yes no I'm looking forward to
them yeah that's badass right there Ken
or John wick is my so good I think I've
watched it 30 times it's every time it's
I need to be on watch John wick do one
better on the first Holi both of them
break hair which John wick shows up one
two three six it don't matter
they're [ __ ] good movies he's very
good at that movie very good counter
resets grey hive to train five hours a
day judge it to just that alone you know
there's some actors that you know like
but I love Tom Cruise and the movie with
Edmund Jamie Foxx I didn't see that
Oh collateral collateral that's what am
I that's one of my the taxi driver Jamie
Foxx no I didn't see that I'm gonna go
check it out see you see Tom Cruise
collateral discotek Chinese discotheque
see I like Tom Cruise when he was in
that Jack Reacher movie he wasn't bad a
blonde in that Jesus Christ the blonde
and Jack breacher I don't know if it's
one or two she's [ __ ] beautiful
no the discotheque see the Chinese disco
scene and [ __ ] whatever it is
collateral collateral that is he's
beautiful he's beautiful in that yoga
you could tell he's far from [ __ ]
eight you can tell he's a mijin that's
[ __ ] moon but besides that I wish I
was five foot eight what's going on we
were you looking for our I have to I
have to capitalize have to do it in
YouTube so I love oh I haven't seen this
you've never this is a great I think
it's a good movie you know within this
he knows of this movie that's not bad
but the Spanish guy
he's married Penelope Cruz pasta
this I think this is even shot Koreatown
Wow
I can't believe you've never seen this
now
he's greatest this guy
Jamie Foxx though the white dude
he was at the Comedy Store a few weeks
ago was watching somebody look at our
boy Emilio Rivera in this movie
there's Emilio coming at you there you
go young Amelia
obvi my Dan is in this
he plays the Mexican gang cause the guy
from a no country homeland yeah he plays
the Mexican gang
this is a great movement this kid is a
great actor
he goes to this girl from time to time I
forget what
so it's Tom Cruise and Jamie Foxx
walking into a disco and that guy that
sit there is the target he's got to
shoot him
but the problem is he he can they've
already shot three or four people the
cops on earth is that he's coming back
to shoot witnesses so those guys you saw
coming at that cops oh I saw this long
smile Joe he's the Hitman or something
like that he's got to get them all in
one night
yeah I saw this a long time ago there's
a very very good movement he's very
[ __ ] good
but the shoots military style this is
how that guy used to teach me how to
shoot fellas a young man military style
which it's your footing you're stepping
I guess I guess I really don't know have
you seen that video Keanu Reeves
switching his weapons as he should like
the military guy says the guns good at
he's full of all this [ __ ] I love what
they do all that stuff he just [ __ ]
people
yeah a fox 29 people after this
and starts taking bodyguards I walk by
one oh there you go you can put a little
ladder and just leave
we gotta go to that place in story
attack second because those had their
that guy's a cop and he's a cop
the great ocular
he does a bunch of my class all the way
back up my every wife
who goes to work jack look at who's a
[ __ ] around
sounds easy going in there stabbing
[ __ ] breaking their necks one
by one the cops [ __ ] up
see they got shot
but the [ __ ] shiny chairs you know
though what the [ __ ] he's gonna do
and I'm like Jamie Foxx in this
and the Mexicans are in there too
Oh
which is crazy
I know you got them care about
Oh
Oh
yeah Tom Cruise's
Scientology 101 Jack there you go
there you go honey these blasts of
people
tremendous
look at the mob boss and bambam
bam-bam-bam singles and that's all he
shoots once in a heart went to the head
he's not even worried about the tops
right now just look at this one to the
heart what's gonna happen he knows
you're doing all walking around he shot
and then walking away walk softly and
that's the thing like we we talk a lot
about like like bad movies or this and
that it like you can really tell when
some like when someone doesn't have the
training that Keanu or Tom Cruise has
and they're doing all these action
movies doesn't look real when these
people but their work and like that they
know it's very because they've seen the
movie where it's like no disrespect the
thing I'm gonna lie to you
the last ten movies Charles Bronson
maybe had no business don't yeah it's
like De Niro now the last ten movies
he's made he has no business doing
because you grudge match was on the LA
TV oh yeah and I turned it on there was
Kevin Hart my scenes were already done
you know and it was weird that it just
didn't look right I did I wasn't
thinking about it at the time I thought
it'd be number one in the box office
alright but while it was on I'd go who
wouldn't go watch this [ __ ] movie do
you know any of them it's weird how many
elements have to come together it's make
it look right to me around how does
Dumbo Charles Bronson fans from the end
and I'll never forget walking out a
death wish for all right like going like
it's all like walk it out up to eight
minutes like going it's old I'm watching
him chase a 20 year old kid in the
streets of New York
Charles Bronson stop yeah stop you could
see him running and the kid running like
a twenty four-year-old kid running and
Charles running the way I would run and
also he's if I had to know Mike I can't
watch this this is unbelievable Steven
Seagal you ever see him running in uh
above the law yeah it's horrible yeah I
had no drugs no running training you
know
how much does it hurt your feelings when
you have to walk out of a move you've
only done that a few times but I like it
I take it serious I don't it hurts my
feelings a lot in more ways than one
especially when you're so looking
forward to looking forward to it and
they blow the movie there's some times
I'll stay you know but I see the part
where they blew the movie why you just
go looking did they had something but
they acted like [ __ ] idiots I'm
excited to see how the Irish kill the
Irishmen are the Irishmen Scorsese's one
for Netflix turns out because it what I
read about it would sound that
interesting is that these guys are older
but it's about this guy looking back on
his life so that'll be interesting to
see how they play it you know it's it's
if you notice that - The Sopranos
they have mob elements but not they
don't even break them down no more
because there's nowhere to go with them
yeah like them John wick who's looking
for John Boy the mob but they don't I
don't say that that they call it
something different than the world or
yeah whatever it is God that movie so
good you can't sell them off you know
more this umbrella was just [ __ ] it up
such a good trying to watch The Sopranos
no I tried about a week ago I had
terrible why it made me sad and like I
hadn't really seen each episode end up
gotcha
HBO put some on now from time to time
aren't they gonna be doing a movie or
something now the prequel that just
agreed to a prequel or something like
that but who knows what they have
you know they're those movies man listen
you gotta remember one thing but I'm not
knocking anybody you notice as you get
older we all get a little lackadaisical
summer says he's not the sasuke's he
used to me
spielberg is not the spielberg he used
to be yeah you know a lot of those
directors they lose it and I don't know
who's the new guy to take over for those
guys because I'll say this thing I look
back at the movies I grew up with John
wick is great but it's rare that I see a
movie and I don't know that's great he
is the nicest kid in the world in the
other world the main room talking to me
said that he stayed home to watch the
movie that won the Academy Award they
couldn't believe how bad it was oh
they're not bad I mean III don't even
insure that I had I get him off from the
Screen Actors Guild I don't watch any he
said I'd look at them the only thing I
want to watch as I tell you I just I
keep forgetting to put it in that's the
only one that he would interest me by
any [ __ ] anything and most of the
superhero movies i watch those they're
fun I enjoy them but they're not great
you know what I mean no they're not for
me
like The Outlaw Josey Wales that's a
great movie I tried to watch [ __ ] one
the woman on the plane I had heard so
many great things about Wonder Woman
right I think after an hour I got a tab
on it it's but then again the other day
I was watching arm again mm-hmm
Armageddon is a good movie but there's a
point I walked out of know again why
were healing when did it get you once
the Russians get involved and [ __ ]
there's no reason to be there no more
that was one movie that they it started
off great for me
I didn't want to watch the end and then
I watch the ending years later they saw
I really would have [ __ ] been mad I
miss you baby and you know this is a
toast man yeah now it's just too [ __ ]
much [ __ ] Joey some shits too much of
mentality I'm like you I'll see right
through it I see right now that's why
John wick I didn't see it in the theater
and at people just like now I think
you're like a female was the one who
said watch John wick maybe you'll like
it so good out calcio I just saw [ __ ]
this is John wick this [ __ ] was on cap
okay I'll watch it Ralphie and I watched
it and he blew me the [ __ ] away but I'm
also Keanu I'm a point blank Point Break
fan it's it was on this so good him and
Swayze this had the [ __ ] to do before he
got hit by the motorcycle you know the
guy happened that jump you know the who
played the guy had died in the plane
Buddy Holly and the crickets the got it
Wow yeah yeah
what break is but what he was still a
[ __ ] human being
yep before he became all crazy he got
hit in the head with the motorcycle
what's his name what is ahead from he
was an hour black sheep
what's it Duncan Trussell used to have
him doing a voiceover audition for Chevy
trucks it's one of the funniest things
I've ever heard
because he's hitting on the woman in New
York giving him instructions and I just
remember the one line he goes how would
you like a backstage pass to my
imagination
have you seen Duncan Trussell no I
missed him the other night I was all set
he was at the store I want to mine he's
making out I'm back I think not next
week but the week after 'mobile Gary
Busey Gary Busey
Gary beefs Gary Busey was still normal
in that [ __ ] moment calories was
young young he was a baby Patrick Swayze
was great
the guy's the red hot chili pepper the
singer was in that yeah the fights at
the surface tonight scenes were [ __ ]
great I mean you know it just but when
you see those movies that sometimes they
like I love the show but they have
horrible fight scenes with son zanuck
yeah just god-awful fight scenes
god-awful anything when it came to that
stuff yep when you know when you put a
lot of money into a movie into a
Hollywood blockbuster that person has to
look like they really if it takes a long
[ __ ] time
to uh make it believable make a boolean
bow you know I think that that movie did
didn't do well with the chick who's the
remember blonde bombshell blonde
ultimate blonde some sometimes it didn't
comic blog there's another atomic blonde
that it went it started off in the right
direction but she couldn't sell it some
people can't sell it yeah
Keanu Reeves really [ __ ] themselves it's
great Tom Cruise [ __ ] sells it Denzel
and man on oh it's one of my all-time
favorite movies it's really weird with
sideways you had more top put on French
Connection the bar room the bar rooms
without the hotel safe I'm gonna go pee
real quick cuz I'm an old man and I
gotta pee every 22 [ __ ] minutes so
hold on I I have it I'll get it ready
but I mean Steve for up for me I I'm I
miss going to the movie theater as much
yeah and they've just made it so
expensive now and the movies the the
quality's gone down
yeah there's something good I'll pay the
money to go say but
something about seeing just the way that
it's different seeing a special from
seeing a comedian life yeah you're right
there are certain movies that I only saw
on TV and then since we're lucky enough
to live here they have those cool movie
places where they show old movies well
it and then you see it on the big screen
you're like oh this is how it's supposed
to be with it with trailers and powie
like that that's part of the best part
of going to a movie
did you ever see taxi driver uh-oh with
DeNiro in his behind mine I when I saw
that on the big screen it was even more
disturbing when I saw Raging Bull on the
big screen it was a different movie when
I saw animal house on the big screen it
was ten times funnier Oh John Belushi
just moving his shoulders would make me
laugh absolutely and then the big
screens were yeah even if you even if
you saw it the first time like like not
only in the theater but you have to see
it in the theater when it's busy or at
least there's some people enjoying the
movie just like stand-up comedy yeah
like if I go to the movies to see a
comedy I that's the only time I go with
other people because normally I go to
the movies at 10 o'clock in the morning
when it's just me and like one other old
guy and I'm like you said I'm outside of
the theater I also don't mind but what
comedies you need an audience
well sure though you know what it was
pretty good you need an audience and
sometimes I like seeing what people but
sometimes I'll go to a movie by myself
hooyo alcohol all the time I love going
by myself because it meet you okay I'll
remember the last little bit one was
like a group of people French cutting
out cleaning up see it yeah cleaning up
the bar popeye here
you know when you saw this background
it's all very believable come on move
there's an old school move bring it in
get your hands out your pockets what's
my name Doyle what mr. Doyle come in you
pick your feet yep
get over there get your hands on your
head I'm gonna keep coming back here so
you clean this bar up keep your eye on
your neighbor he dropped something that
belongs to you stand up there naughty I
saw that booze don't heroin [ __ ]
only you would hide it under the bar so
the cops came in the it's not your pills
with big barbiturates
the opioids now look at weed came in an
envelope
[Music]
alright I'm not on the [ __ ] cigarette
machine this is classic [ __ ] milkshake
[Music]
all right come over here you and you hey
whiskers come on it was Danny disrespect
look see that guy fall in the subway
that was the commercial for it you know
trailer the trailer you remember the
trailer
[ __ ] yeah I was a kid in New York City
that said filmed in New York where it
happened you dyed your dick
that's so cool I'm like what are you
[ __ ] him I'm literally a stirry my
new hat yeah I think he got shot in
Brooklyn the Bronx or whatever but these
are movies that the characters are very
believable they did the work you know
yeah we had the guy that did the movie
uh colors okay Li Shan I had the guy
that was based off of a Sean Penn just
lived with the guy for six weeks Wow he
did his work you know for another three
weeks he went to a police academy and
learn the rules almost last time Sean
Penn was in something he's great at he
just to the movie a couple we eat and
maybe add to it they're trying to make
him a leading like tough guy and
something I don't know if the movie was
good enough but when you do those roles
you really got a dime yourself into
those things like when Joey Gallo got
shot what's his name was there the guy
from law and order
a Jerry Orbach was there as Jerry Orbach
was studying a role to do Joey Gallo no
other gangster will ever go come join
our was so [ __ ] crazy at the time and
so full of himself that he let Jerry
Orbach
[ __ ] can hang out with him to learn all
about mafia code - babe you know the
slang in the patois and [ __ ] like that
well they're not running stories and
with the new one like the heist one
that's coming out it's no heist or truck
heist or they're just right they just
have themes and the story is not that
I'm making movies off of video games I
still rampage is coming out you know
good stories good characters the movies
will our movies I grew up on movies I
know how the excitement that it brought
to me yeah when I walked into a movie
theater you smelled the popcorn it's the
grayness and now you walk in and the
first reaction is I'm about to get
ripped off yes yeah I'm about to pay
three dollars and 85 cents for a box of
[ __ ] mop balls like you get four
boxes for $2 at 7-eleven
yeah it's an expensive night if you take
a girl to like up what's the movie
theater in Lebanon the lonely or the
[ __ ] other our clothes I think maybe
our clients my dad for example and don't
get me wrong [ __ ] our client is great
it's worth it it's if you want to be a
white person the article is the way to
go they even tell you where you're
sitting
yeah now when you get there they'll tell
you what row who well who you sitting
next to get a beer glass of wine they
got the one Hollywood's got a chicken
sausage sandwich of Italian bread was
sausage and peppers Jesus Christ I went
to a movie that one time way before the
podcast world even got popular yeah I
did a movie podcast and part of the
podcast is you haven't go see a movie
and talk about it okay so I took my wife
to a movie I went there with a $100 bill
I didn't think about it like I had a
hundred dollar bill when I got home I
like $18 left
I didn't think about till the next day
like we went to the ArcLight
it's not 80 [ __ ] dollars we walk
because we lived three blocks away in
Hollywood with him paper Park Emma it
was a [ __ ] 18 hours between and the
years ago yeah this had to be nine years
ago this we were still living in the
valley so to total still living in
Hollywood you have to be 2009 2009 2008
we had just gotten yeah it's probably a
hundred not the same dude it's like
20-something the [ __ ] popcorn is five
a six way above that now is it really
yeah a [ __ ] hit you there that combo
package is 1895 yeah popcorn a touch
more than a drink and a box of candy you
don't save any money with those no no no
no you know and you know that's what the
lemma is that you're gonna sit next to
nice white people nobody's in the yellow
nobody's on a smoke pot I have smoked
dope in there I wouldn't know what that
was saying one one time to watch the
Clint Eastwood movie about the [ __ ]
Asian oh we have a Rick Ramos and we
sparked the joint on [ __ ] soul out
there we spoke to join up and now we're
in the theater yeah we had that place
crazy talk in the old days you didn't go
to a movie theater without smelling weed
yeah but not in the theater you know in
the fear oh Jesus Reilly's the movie
star did you rip open a fun imagining 16
year old me excuse me sir can you please
put that out you know you wouldn't even
have the audacity you would smell it and
look straight you don't know nothing you
don't know nothing you don't need to
know nothing
let me give us a shout out real quick
these are the shoutouts I gave yesterday
but since we're not putting out the
podcast I just redid him for today my
brother Nathan from stay comes sent us
some t-shirts he sent her some boxes he
sent us a picture I want to give him a
big big shout out I didn't know how to
[ __ ] say your last name Nathan so
[ __ ] no last names the Cronin
brothers you bad [ __ ] Ben Riley
Allen sterk
Michael Grimm Mel Kevin Glenn Cole Shaw
Eric doe drought
and the rest of the [ __ ] church
family I love you [ __ ] and don't
forget I'll be at the Santa Fe casino
the first week of April the 5th and the
6th of April and then I'll be [ __ ]
somewhere I don't [ __ ] Oh Columbus
for 4/20 [ __ ] bring your [ __ ]
reefer we're going to jail like Jim
Morrison did the new season of this does
not happen come on yeah it started yep
they gave it a really shitty times late
at night like on Fridays yeah
the shame there's some good stories the
ship ayran bowers killed it this year
his story
my story was so [ __ ] shitty you took
me on a ride with that story now it was
so [ __ ] shitty yeah for some people
know me but just I didn't know what else
to say and I want to get off my chest
kind of story you know it was one of
those things I just wanted to get off my
chest that still wants me to tell it I
got left back like that still head for
the reason I got left back I didn't get
led by if I got left back cause I'm
stupid all right
I can live with that I gotta live back
as I fell in love with some [ __ ]
chicks little skinny [ __ ] then then I
was like we should never even game with
them and never even saw it and I was
walking around like [ __ ] Johnny Gobots
Howry again twelve twelve but I was 12
Lee's dirty 29 walking around coming
this [ __ ] yeah make him believe like
that so people do they want to cover
some people like cuddling is good not
you that when you pay rent there's no
cut pay rent you got a shoulder chocha
you think Harvey let you still and and
[ __ ] that's like a favor Pitt in comedy
right now you know Harvey bit it's the
funny thing Harvey will let you stay oh
I'm not really modeling my life after
Harvey but what do you think you think
Harvey you let you stay over on this
couch for free and your feet on the Chan
[ __ ] God won't what are you [ __ ]
crazy that's true he probably wouldn't
yeah this robe on all of the advice you
gave him for years sounds a lot like the
advice we give him Harvey advice -
that's [ __ ] up though yeah I was
taking a shower and I'm like would want
somebody to watch you take a shower how
[ __ ] crazy is that where is your head
like the what we'll hold on one second
let me take a shower once we take a show
it's like as soon as somebody would say
that to me I'm out of there you know
what
no and you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
thinking about I'm washing my hair like
what would suddenly take it to watching
more fat [ __ ] with soap laying down his
[ __ ] goofy what is wrong with these
[ __ ] people I think I think it'll
lead to something else yeah it's like
they don't I don't know so what's going
on under here man and many scripts
what's hauling you sell me these [ __ ]
script [ __ ] you was the neck the
tour I didn't call him Nicky pilots
that's his new name everybody a new pile
he's got more pilots of American
Airlines pilots everybody a loop I'll
yesterday I had to telling you the Nicky
pilots well that's the great thing about
stand-up that's why I love it because
you don't need anybody else's permission
no if you get out there and you get the
immediate response you don't need to
wait for this person work let somebody
else read this or no you just go do it
and it's made me appreciate look I love
writing I love coming up with ideas I
love all that stuff but it's the only
thing that's really done for me it's
made me appreciate stand-up comedy more
where I go okay well the writing takes a
discipline
like I've been so busy with these
showing writers in the last couple weeks
I haven't even written a [ __ ]
sentence in the book yeah I charge the
computer up last night cuz asclad
thought my chain my day was gonna be
different but it ended up being
completely different while I anticipated
but I'm gonna get back to just finished
his [ __ ] chapter and then decide
which way I'm gonna go with this what
I'm missing was the discipline I had
been to right yeah it takes a certain
discipline you know it takes it has to
fit into a Lich yes like from now on at
this time I'll do this to this I'll do
this to this you know and that's how it
fits I gotta find the time to really
fill in every day at that specific time
like Netflix is holding me up in so many
[ __ ] levels it's pathetic I want to
plan a tour I want to do a bunch of
things because I know that once Netflix
gives me a date I go all out
I hire a bunch of writers and I thought
to go oh I'll every night for 30 minutes
and then what's that special shot you
won't see it with Joey
so that special comes up now weekend is
when you'll see me again there's no
reason to go out with no material once
you burn the Lund [ __ ] TV there's no
reason to keep showing it to people who
had just seen it on Netflix God has
nothing worse than me seeing you on
Netflix and then you show up with the
same hour nothing happened nothing was
accumulated I wasted 30 [ __ ] dollars
I want to see up 30 more minutes yeah I
like that bit from there wish she does
that but that's it yes I don't want them
and it'll be different you'll have a
destroyed me this [ __ ] last time I shot
a special I was going out there for six
months flaunt during yeah when old [ __ ]
trying to steal from this but he yes I
don't like that feeling I want you to
see a fool that's all I don't go to
every town every eight [ __ ] months at
least do not agents want you to do right
sixteen months I know in 16 months I'll
have a new Ford yeah
I might have a no closer I might have
something in the middle you heard before
but I know a new shell it's a loose show
I'm different you'll be different and
we'll all be different but I can't do
this [ __ ] that they want you to do now
that's not the way you used to be done
when I first got here your year broke up
you did you tape eight episodes of a 17
episode season those episodes you didn't
go anywhere you went to a store on
Friday inside then you worked on your
new material yeah and then you shut your
special and then you [ __ ] one on the
road to support the special these
sandals have y'all all [ __ ] if it's
all a tie three weeks a month you know
what then I can't write or I can't see
my family I have to have a complete
balance yeah that's the difficult thing
is like not just finding the balance
with everything else you want to do with
your time in your life but just the
balance to stand up cuz now I gotta be
honest I feel pressure at the Comedy
Store or like I started working new bits
but I'm doing the early shows on Fridays
and Saturdays I'm very grateful for the
stage time but I want to do well every
time I'm up there or else I'm not gonna
get a spot I'm not famous so I need to
start finding little other places around
town and start working stuff out because
then I go out on the road and I want to
give the people that the 20 percent of
the people that are gonna come out and
see me I want to give him something
never heard before something that never
seen before so I know it's like to open
up for a comic two times in a row in a
town and he has the same [ __ ] set and
me as a feature I'm count
oh yeah to the vrae them I can't do that
you gotta switch it around yes you gotta
give him a different angle of your life
from what you're seeing or what's going
on now and that's why I didn't like that
whole thing that's why I'm doing what
I'm doing though pretty much mom two
shows and I act you know there's 20 30
new minutes of material since you went
back to see me last time and then I move
on now I'm not be I won't be back on the
East Coast till November in New York
that's a complete different 30 minutes
yeah I might do 50 20 you might hear it
still funny I sell it got yet but I want
to see me in different perspective these
[ __ ] people or you know no I'm just
waiting on Netflix because those six
weeks that leading up to it leading up
to a special get released I'll go on a
writing spree
because I can't ready for a fine to
booked just a book and the night going
out with Lee and young guys I get this
[ __ ] special it's not like I go to
the store once a week you know with
Rizzo Johnny Rock or I pay them get
rooms every night new rooms let's go try
on the material get the Agostino with a
[ __ ] tape recorder and Lee let's go
and between everybody everybody comes up
with a tag and next thing you know you
got 15 minutes yeah and my own 15
minutes and a little [ __ ] tie-in and
you get yourself the tremendous Netflix
half-hour special that's how you do it
that's granular do an embedded series so
six weeks prior to that thing being
released there's footage every [ __ ]
Monday of us going different places me
going to acupuncture me bull gonna buff
on bull you know the whole [ __ ] deal
we'll get some excitement it's man
without a plan is not a man though and
then every level you have to have a plan
that's so weird this is very inspiring I
needed this podcast this is the part to
the to run Rogen at David Goggins the
Navy SEAL on there that got me like to
jujitsu taking cold showers starting to
wrong yeah you've got to look at that
but now I'm going alright Uncle Joe
you're motivating me the same way where
I'm going what do I really want how do I
put together a game plan for it I answer
these emails every week I answer these
emails and it's really crazy how yeah
Joey we like the podcast Joey we don't
like the podcast Joey what must you do
this Joey why must you do that but every
80 minutes I get the guy that wants to
be a star mm-hmm and it really bothers
me the way they talk to me every for
every eight emails that I get when it
meets on the Facebook Messenger or
whatever one of those emails is a guy
that's involved with get quick writ
scheme
never and they don't understand that I
used to have that mentality for
everything that was my whole [ __ ]
life was I in this [ __ ] jackpot
but that never really happens you know
yeah you might get people some of the
time but eventually you're gonna get
[ __ ] caught yeah you want to earn
your black belt you don't want the Elvis
black though god forbid you think you're
better than you are
yeah god forbid and it's so weird I get
these calls from you know these emails
from these kids and they think it's just
like that and I know I look at this [ __ ]
I investigate a little bit I know what
they're doing it's no big giant sting to
me if they came direct to me I would
help him out but that's they come at me
in a different way and that was one kid
that was [ __ ] relentless for a while
oh he was a man of a thousand stories
okay he won at Lee's job he wanted to
produce movies he wanted uh-hum ID I
mean they was hysterical because did
even live in LA no no no no no no no he
did not live in LA he made the series
yeah he had he was the man that had 20
ideas but meanwhile I mean it it was
getting to the point where how you knew
he was an ass maybe only live with me
Wow like it was one of those [ __ ]
morons like that they really think and
from time to time yeah how I bring a
musician down here mm-hm and I like
bringing rappers on here and a celebrity
from time to time whatever you assume a
celebrity of [ __ ] is only timed of time
I just like bringing my friends on here
yeah and well that looks low what we're
going through so people don't know that
listen we believe when we cut - yeah
there's no [ __ ] secrets here there's
no there's no quick quick
rich scheme here this is 27 [ __ ]
years I've been doing this yeah and for
20 of those years
seen so many people [ __ ] come come and
go that had way more to offer than I did
I wouldn't say that yes I did yes they
did they were good-looking they could
act they could they just quit they just
gave up when the secret everything's
persistent before the father's dream
happened they just gave up like we're
giving up this is too much of it you
have to be gay the live in LA they gave
themselves that excuse all right that
stupid [ __ ] excuse off here and just
can't handle on no it just [ __ ] me up
you know I could just uh it they don't
understand that I saw these guys before
like I love every show I gotta there's
always treat creepy promoters now hey
man I got the show and my sale in April
I'm not interested
first of all I'm here to [ __ ] do a
show it's eight o'clock it's Konami time
why you even talking business that's
your first [ __ ] silent amateurish
yeah if you really have a show and then
you know and then you hit me with a
number that you're making as much money
as I'm making that's never gonna happen
either yep
that's never gonna happen you might as
well call Bongo Jones because that's not
happening me I'm getting most of that
register you understand me I'm taking
that register yeah you know why because
when you're [ __ ] dreaming of your
what I'm doing I'm doing it I'm on
Twitter tweeting [ __ ] stand up grab
your dick yeah telling you where I'm
gonna be three weeks from now I'm
talking to Lee about what guess the
schedule when and how this is 1015 hours
a week is you're doing this never mind
[ __ ] stand-up and writing and
performing and who's late who bumps you
you know so my wing doesn't go there
they have no [ __ ] idea yeah you know
Lee's having a great time when like I
told Lee I go I don't I don't have a
fortune how long have a [ __ ] crystal
ball I just know that you getting on
stage is gonna open up your eyes to find
what you truly love so true that's all I
could tell you that's the only [ __ ]
guarantee I could saving that's do that
you might Tony assume now be the biggest
film maker in Howey
it's because you got onstage mm-hmm
that's what and you'll go to me yet but
some of you go yeah you know he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] we used to be a stand-up
comic it doesn't matter he got up off
the couch and he did something uh that's
the thing getting out of your comfort
zones when you started the podcast where
he would that first step he went to
Africa ended up in Israel you know I'm
saying
yeah I'm leavin get up you just wanted a
[ __ ] you won't have somebody give you
the slow ride on a [ __ ] short ship
yep but meanwhile you buy you the
universe knows when you try there's
something about the universe that really
really knows when you try and unless you
lived it you'll never know that you'll
never know what it's likely to need $400
to make you $1,000 rent and Steve
quality says he has a fire Bilal a gig
for you this weekend
and you get off the phone you hang up
the phone and you just go then you go
how did that happen and you know why
that happened because two weeks ago on a
Sunday night you had your beginnings of
the flu but Joey Diaz was doing the show
on a Sunday at 10 o'clock and you went
down and ate a bag of dicks
he puts your plaster [ __ ] with your
emotions and you will up there in front
of 80 Yahoo's and hey the bag of dicks
and then he went home and nothing
happened that's why you got that four
hours it's not because you sat at home
that night so every time you go to the
fourth wall every time you go to Valley
College every time you go to that place
I want you to do it like this an
imaginary time card and just call it
this because I want you to know that
eventually that cheff gonna come in the
mail and on the second half I don't want
you to look at that check and go why is
this check $10,000 because you did this
a lot yeah you did this
over time that you gave up you gave up
on even getting paid you ever give up on
getting paid always like you just get
and what I'm doing is the motion of your
tongue
looking at but everybody in this fight
that listens to this podcast goes to
work everything they look on a wall and
you take that [ __ ] card and you push
it in yeah it's the same thing
how many speaker used to have one of
those for all the employers before they
everybody does you know so whether you
get on stage whether you go help
somebody move whether you go hold the
camera for somebody for one day or hold
the cord all that comes back to you so
that day when you do get that $10,000
check you don't think you're [ __ ]
crazy yep and it's I know you earned it
you all know you were you know you
earned it you know you [ __ ] in there
there's no shortcuts to anything and
you're becoming a better person along
the way my god the journey is it's
everything such a [ __ ] day I was
sitting there going oh come on in there
love a rapist he would think about that
like you sit there going how come
everybody ribs people and they enjoy and
they put that every [ __ ] night I turn
the news on and they're looking for a
rapist every [ __ ] nightmare you know
this guy he's a rapist oh yeah they well
you get to be 55 you start thinking
about why did I become a Mason why
didn't I become an artist why didn't I
[ __ ] enjoy the service you start
getting stupid [ __ ] like that when you
smoke pot I don't want you to lose when
I said to myself how come I never
enjoyed raping people like that like
[ __ ] falling out of a tree and just
dick them smacking and ripping my hands
off and choking and sticking hiya
that is the most violent I need to do it
on an individual and I thought about the
first time I ever saw rape was Charles
Bronson Deathwish that is the most
horrible rape scene that you'll get to
see as a young man that I shouldn't even
belong to that movie think they should
have stopped me and said you know
there's a rape scene in this but I want
in there anyway it's a horrible [ __ ]
rape scene and then the second time was
maybe the Outlaw Josey Wales and you and
I found out about my mother and you know
you just take a [ __ ] like this why did I
become a rapist you know
I become a lobbyist of Julia but uh just
weird where life takes you and the
journey of it is so [ __ ] important
sorry I didn't make any mistakes in in
any of those places I went there will he
will read bombed at the halftime of the
Buffalo Sabres aim that time it came I'd
be not paying for that
yeah you get paid for all those stupid
[ __ ] things that you did when you win
so many calls and says hey come today
you know me free shows I did the
Hollywood not a free shows dude doing
Hollywood cops free just really like
free like non-stop you pay $1 to park
yes you actually pay the park yeah and
your gas and I did you get to go help
Steve Simone who's got a room at the
Viper Room and then sometimes you show
up and they want to give you a free diet
coke oh yeah now I have to pay six
dollars for this after I paid ten the
park to go you know for free for people
a dog don't even want to be there for
comedy please say you don't know how
many times I hated this like like I got
like that oh like somebody says don't
pay you 50 bucks but you go into them
and you get sodas and like a sandwich
and they hit you with a 22-hour tab in
your house
anything to pick up the tab for the
[ __ ] cheese sandwiches [ __ ] it's so
but if you really put the work in you
know when I tell people all the time
it's Mick Jagger said it best you can't
get what you want but you get what you
need mm-hmm if you come to me and you go
well you know I can't make a living off
counted well what's your rent when I
read this 1,300 IQ I can't live the love
of standards and what's your car payment
you know me I have a Maserati you're not
gonna work
you ain't on it it's really weird we
talked about it couple weeks ago I get
you have to strip yourself down enough
and then you get like a little number on
there like you figure out a way how to
steep you figure out a way how to
finagle Steve some on and - right
here's couch for two weeks a month when
you're in town yeah
you pay [ __ ] 100 a week and I'm the
couch and you're like that's but you're
only making 1,200 a month so it's your
car payment you're not taking everything
you drive it everywhere like you're
basically baked breaking even on the
road if you are on the road your first
year did tribble runs you would make
$9,000 oh that's you would make the
crisis 9000 [ __ ] bubbles you ever
look back and go how did I survive all
this I now look back on some of those
she or someone going I don't know how I
did it you gotta remember that I when I
got into it I had nothing else all right
when you have nothing else when you
double-check everything when yes
double-check your catalog and you know
you go listen there is nothing else I
can honestly tell you that I can
realistically do yeah like what can I do
okay if I go talk wendy's to become a
chef I still gotta wash dishes for six
months it's gonna make me a chef like
everything I'm gonna have to do I'm
gonna have to pay my dues in the
weirdest [ __ ] way yes and I'm gonna
be a slave to what I do but if I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do stand-up and that
means sleeping in my car taking weird
showers weird people you know it just
epic I knew right away like it took me I
thought stand-up was this weird thing
from outer space it wasn't a weird thing
from outer space it's you gotta roll up
your sleeve times and it's not this
really weird picture I'm sure if we Styx
would stand up in a year or two he'll go
I'm moving back to Boston my friend said
ain't there's tons of room up the thing
I could stay with my mom I could pay no
rent I can pay my car payment my student
loans of pain and I could do comedy in
Boston for two years and nobody'll see
me yeah that's what I'm what no comes to
you
one day you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
I'm stripping down the 650 a month Jack
so I need to make this 650 a month I'm
pretty sure you make 400 a month and
then eight months later you do make 650
a month and you start making 900 month
and then there comes a time where you
make a thousand month and you're like oh
- I'm [ __ ] rich check this is like
[ __ ] stealing yes it's exciting it's
like I looked at my ability yesterday
and it wasn't well it's not a lot of
money to anybody else but to me I looked
at it and I remembered I would have had
to work a hundred hours telemarking a
hundred hours at the gym a hundred hours
at the pizza place a hundred hours at
the Comedy Store they get what I paid
yet got paid yesterday for in half an
hour
put your to work that's what it was
that's exactly what I was thinking
yesterday I went this is 18 years of
hard work of not giving up and take away
all the work just mentally not tapping
out just saying no I'm done just not
giving up that's what it was you know
it's the expectations that America has
known and everywhere we we've lost that
you know uh a union is for you you know
all these things we've lost everybody
that's everything else them you know I
talked to Lee what Lee and I have had
thousands of conversations about college
and how he went it seemed like you know
he'll tell you he would have had the
same career with or without I'm missing
right now yep you can learn to edit
online you can learn through Apple
resume and all this I mean there's
different programs for what TV shows and
stuff like that but it breaks my heart
that we pay school loans because you
know it just I still have them I'm in my
40s and I still have school you still
play them yeah will you pay a month
well cuz I'm poor they adjust him for
who come but it's still a hundred and
something a month every month what are
you gonna left oh you don't even want to
know it's this guy I have a heart attack
they're gonna charge off before I can
pay them off cuz there were years when I
was out here when I was the fat James
years I'd have a car I was working every
day you deferred them I deferred them
they just yes
yeah it just keeps the interest in
everything it's just a [ __ ] layaway
because they would have been as much as
my rent in those years I gather and it
was barely pay my I just got they found
me after 20 years and hit me with a bill
and I got my Eternia so this is what
we're gonna give you if not go [ __ ]
yourself and they took it it wasn't they
lose money on and we just didn't pay a
lot of fake we didn't have all the fake
they wanted but they rigged me they
think me heavy they they've rigged me
they do okay yeah right now I'm hanging
like three times we're supposed to pay
it two and a half times just to try to
get it off instead of fifteen two paid
off in ten yeah it's it's a hard thing
to have over you I don't think people
understand what it's like to start your
life in the - that's bad
it's a [ __ ] bad feelings I'm bad for
the way money go to school or work for a
year to really like keep yourself going
it's just it's it's or it's rough out
there you know I have a dear friend that
called a couple reasons I get them
moving California isn't losing avoiding
move on it it doesn't want you to know
that that building wholefoods around the
corner yeah which means in a year
Lisl it comes to being go I'm moving out
of Studio City because I can't afford it
oh I want to move right now but I can't
because Han leaf it's too expensive just
to move in the area just move just cuz
it's like just to be in the same area
idea I think we have the rents have done
here in just the last four years over
they've doubled in four years I want
know that I won't see you you're with a
woman helps where it gets 118 degrees in
the summer you mean after you have to
live right I thought about cuz that's
2004 one-bedroom here
yeah oh that's crazy yeah no please in
the studio you gotta be in the studio
and bite the bullet and your mixer
there's no this is all gonna and then
they're not they're buying houses to
knock them down and [ __ ] them gold apart
who's up I don't know because they know
it they know that this area is about the
boom once they put the Whole Foods er
yeah they do they're not they got the
train station that builders around the
train station all the Burbank after the
holiday and they're about to get [ __ ]
deserved and the wonder my landlord
doesn't want to fix anything they're
like we'd love you to move out we'd love
you to move because like right now
paying 14 so like we would love change
they want you to move on no no you might
as well stay cuz you're not gonna get a
big deal I'm not unless you move a
paper-thin walls yeah especially if you
move all the way out to the how agile
hell what the [ __ ] is that gonna do for
you right now we're very fortunate blast
a bro we're fortunate that we're in this
area and that there's no [ __ ] drama
yeah one night you want on the road soon
my brother yeah I'm doing uh the Jeff
just for last tour through Canada like
April was lured it's me tone Bell and I
think this girl Sarah Schaefer who
seemed nice I met her once at the ice
house so it's a bunch of comics I've
never really worked with before so I'm
looking and it's towns in Canada I've
never been to and you're doing either
going to Denver - yeah then I'm gonna be
at Denver for Mother's Day weekend and
as you were saying like changing up your
act I'm like well I got to do my mom
some of my mom's stuff for Mother's Day
weekend
I love Denver you still one of my
favorite people in Los Angeles
Salani Joey it's always nice just to
listen man like I said it's really great
to get people in hand different group
but it's also nice just to get my
friends in here
time to time and we could just talk
about what's going on you know I thought
that uh there was a little heavy with
our [ __ ] son of Jesus the other day
so I wanted just to give us a little
breather just and after yesterday's
podcast with the [ __ ] we both I got
sorry again my apologies too we were
walking on my apologies to Lee we got
really [ __ ] high yesterday like I
said I've been with you guys for six
years we had a [ __ ] really bad THC
accident yesterday either those people
doubled up their edibles or our system
[ __ ] broke down either we gotta work
harder or they gotta be on it or they're
really on their toes you call me at 5:30
in the morning smoking bong hits
you're lucky cuz it was just one of
those things but anyway I want to thank
you I'm gonna be at Santa Fe the casino
down at Albuquerque on 4th April 5th and
6th and I'm also gonna be at the
Columbus fully boat with Kate Quigley
for four [ __ ] 20 but before I
go I gotta talk to you people about
something okay listen are you hiring
right now we I know y'all a lot of you
own your business player you hiring
post in the position to a job sites I'm
waiting and waiting for the right people
to see it that never works all right zip
recruiter knew there was a smarter way
so they built a platform that finds the
right job candidates for you typically
learns that what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job these invitations have
revolutionize how you find your next
hire in fact 80% of employers who post a
job on the dip recruiter can a quality
candidate through the site and just Ray
one day one day and Zim Bakula doesn't
stop there they even spotlight the
strongest application she received so
you never ever ever miss a great match
the right candidates are out there
and zip recruiter is how you find them
businesses of all sizes have trusted zip
recruiter for their hiring need so right
now today you're sitting there like
where am I gonna fit there you go the
church family they could try the
prakruti for free again tried zip
recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruiter calm slash
Church that's all you need to do and
they're gonna sign you up for free that
zip recruiter dot coms last Church zip
recruiter is the smart way to hire you
understand me number two I want to thank
on it for being there since day one
sending me goodies every month they send
me shroom tech I get kettlebells I get
club bells I get the protein when they
have it and you know what man I feel
better overall I am my performance is
better my shoulders are strong
everything is gonna work it out I can't
get you a deal on the kettlebells of the
club bells but as far as [ __ ]
supplements at the turn I get to ten
percent off the liver right the house
totally calm a little bit great
selection of supplements that they have
the jerky I mean it just never ends with
them or will be running about two weeks
and he'll tell you where they're going
go to at that time and press in church
get 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] house I want to thank my
brother my brother Steve Simone and go
see him on the Just for Laughs tour of
Canada I want to thank the Christ coisa
ass
I want to thank that [ __ ] that just came
out of my ass but most importantly I
want to thank new people for the love
and the support that you give this and
we'll see you guys Monday morning with
TJ English the author of the corporation
have a great weekend be careful stay
black knuckle Joey loves you thank you
John thank you how to walk harder this
very inspired
[Music]